c'est l'heure d'un faux intox dans votre
pari direct ce soir avec anthony st
léger bond soit anthony
anthony de nouvelles images détournées
circule sur les réseaux sociaux et
affirme illustrer le regain de tension
on en parlait récent entre le rwanda et
la république démocratique du congo le
contexte en deux mots c'est celui ci un
ca francs contre les rebelles du m23 et
à des militaires congolais dans l'est de
la rd congo depuis plusieurs semaines
kinshasa qui accuse kigali de soutenir
cette offensive ce que dément le rwanda
laurent da contre lequel ont manifesté à
la semaine dernière à des milliers de
congolais à goma rassemblement qui a
dégénéré et c'est ce contexte que
viennent nourrir plusieurs un fox donc
la première ce soir c'est une vidéo que
l'on retrouve essentiellement sur what's
app et sur laquelle nous ont interpellé
les internes ou plusieurs internautes en
tout cas j'en profite pour dire qu'en
cas de doute sur une image vous pouvez
évidemment vous rendre sur le site le
compte facebook de france 24 et des
observateurs de france 24 plus
précisément mais aussi nous envoyer un
message à ce numéro via whatsapp voilà
pour la petite parenthèse vidéo très
violente dont je vous parlais par
conséquent je ne vous la montrerai pas
vous verrez vous verrez uniquement une
capture d'écran on y voit un jeune
garçon pieds et mains liés suspendu sur
une poutre qui est posée sur deux blocs
de béton il est frappé lourdement au
visage et les internautes qui partagent
cette vidéo d'affirmer vous le voyez
qu'il s'agit d'un étudiant congolais
torturé au rwanda la recherche d'image
inversée nous ramène à un tweet du 16
janvier 2000 à 21 bien avant donc cette
résurgence de violences résurgence 1
parce que les tensions entre galères
kigali pardon et avec kinshasa sont ne
date pas d'hier elles sont historiques
mais anthony cette vidéo elle elle n'a
pas été tourné au rwanda effectivement
et c'est en fait la langue parlée dans
la vidéo qui va nous donner qui va nous
mettre sur la piste un plusieurs
organisations de fact checking dont
congo tchèque contact ou de confirmer
aux observateurs de france 24 qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d'une langue parlée ni au
rwanda ni en rdc un journaliste ghanéen
explique qu'il s'agit du dac banni par
les parents vignon a envie un million de
personnes mais uniquement au ghana scène
très vraisemblablement donc tourné au
ghana est la traduction des dialogues ça
prend un peu le contexte s'il s'agit
d'une punition infligée à une personne
accusée de vol deuxième exemple vous
voulez nous parler anthony un message
qui prétend qu'un pont a été construit
illégalement toujours entre le rwanda et
le congo est effectivement là c'est ce
qu'affirme dans cette publication
facebook photos à la pluie un pont jeté
illégalement sans l'accord des autorités
de la rdc depuis 2011 et d'autre même
d'assurer que c'est un passage
clandestin ce pont entre pour des
militaires rwandais déguisé en rebelle
congolais un mot doit attirer
l'attention dans cette publication c'est
celui ci rosie du nom de cette rivière
qui traverse plusieurs pays et qui prend
son nom du chiot dans le lac kivu
plusieurs pays le rwanda le burundi est
ici donc la rd c'est mais ce de manière
tout à fait légale puisque cette rivière
c'est sur laquelle passe effectivement
le pont en question entre le rwanda et
la rdc mais de manière tout à fait
légale je le disais puisqu'il s'inscrit
dans un projet dans le cas d'un projet
hydroélectrique hors ou zizi 3 démarrer
en 2011 le pont lui a été construit
entre 2014 et 2015 et ils permettent
d'acheminer du matériel qui permet donc
de construire ce barrage dont
profiteront la rdc le burundi et le
rwanda on ne se quittent pas là dessus
pas là dessus vous voulez nous parler
d'une déclaration de guerre factice
également à l heure en a qui aurait
déclaré officiellement la guerre au
congo affirmation qui émanent de
plusieurs utilisateurs de facebook il ya
une semaine cette image à l'appui c'est
un document qui est en fait un
photomontage avec c'est vrai une
déclaration qui semble somme toute assez
officielle et elle reprend tout
bonnement la charte graphique à des
déclarations des forces armées à rodez
on a aussi le logo qui est absolument
authentiques mais l image trompeuse un
faux-pas cieux apparences on le sait
très ressemblantes au communiqué de
presse authentique voici un exemple de
communiqués de presse authentique vous
en conviendrez c'est assez ressemblants
mais déclaration de guerre qui est une
fake news dont démenti avoir sur le
compte twitter des forces armées
rwandaises publication faite sur twitter
donc le 14 juin et d'autres rédactions
de l'intérieur trouvé aucune trace d'un
quelconque communiqué d'une quelconque
déclaration de guerre que ce soit sur le
site de l'armée rendu et rwandaise ou
sur ces réseaux sociaux merci beaucoup
anthony c'était un fou intox avec
anthony st léger se soit enfin on attend
que ça retrouver bien évidemment sur
notre site internet france 24 points
comme voit la fin de cette première demi
heure de paris dira qu rester avec nous
la formation continue